hi everyone
it's the sound on can I get a feedback
on the chat whether you can hear me and
see me
okay I can see me at least and I hope
you can hear me yes I've got a feedback
you can hear me
perfect welcome everyone I am so happy
you want to join me for this today this
is this is a webinar it's a version of a
workshop I gave recently at the
celebration our conference and this is
the very first time I'm doing any
screencast so you are actually just
watching me learning to do fancy stuff
on the internet and I hope I don't mess
up too much if I do I hope you can
forgive me so this is this is the
plotting anything with ggplot2 webinar
the corona Edition but it simply means
is that I figured we're all stuck at
home or at least in a very peculiar
situation right now and we we might as
well try to make the best of it this was
or this is like a four or five hour
workshop we would won't do all of it
today but we will we will take the first
half so expect that this will take
between two and three hours more or less
and and then we'll take the later half
at another convenient time my my
planning and my schedule is also a bit a
bit strained at the moment so hopefully
sometime next week so just a quick word
about me um my name is Thomas I'm a
software engineer at our studio where I
work mainly with with the graphics Tech
in our I'm currently the I'm not the
official maintainer of ggplot2 but I am
one of the main maintainer of Gd plot to
we're small team but I also work another
graphic related stuff and and try to
improve the the benchmarking a lot I was
once a bioinformatician before I dived
into the world of
pure software engineering so I have that
in my backpack and I do block a bit on
data imagine Escom you can follow me on
twitter which is also where you'll
probably see the next date for the rest
of the of this this webinar and I'm also
on github obviously where you can you
see all my my different projects so
about today this evening this morning
this night whatever time it is for you
we're going to talk about four main
sections the first we're going to talk
about is the grammar of graphics if you
don't if you have ever wondered why it's
called ggplot it's because it's an
implementation of grammar of graphics eg
and then flooding of course and and the
grammar of graphic is a theoretical
construct so the first part will be
purely theoretical if you if you look
forward to getting into the nitty-gritty
coding at the beginning I'm sorry to
disappoint you my feeling is that it's
it's extremely important to understand
the the theory behind ggplot2 to learn
to use it efficiently which is why I'm
starting off in that way it's it's not
gonna be too long and boring hopefully
and I hope that you come out and the
other end actually understanding why we
do what we do in GT plot2 so but one
thing is of course theory and then after
this I'm going to talk about the ggplot2
API which is like the programmatic
reflection of this theory and these are
the two parts that we'll be discussing
today and then in a later webinar I'm
going to talk about what I'm calling
beyond ggplot2 Gd plot two has has been
successful in nurturing a quite quite
vibrant ecosystem of additional packages
that improve on the
on the current ggplot2 what I would call
base ggplot2 improving that by adding
new features and new capabilities to the
API and then in the end for the last day
I will I'll talk about this idea of
drawing anything like what how do we
draw anything how how do we look at
something and deconstruct it and figure
out how could we possibly do this with
ggplot2 okay so that's about today there
is also a lot about not not about today
which are all quite integral to working
with our really and and therefore also
quite integral to to working with data
visualization and ggplot2 well we won't
talk about it because it would simply be
too much to to have in our in a workshop
or webinar and there is also a lot of
fantastic fantastic articles fantastic
material online that you can that you
can learn about so one important part
about plotting of course is data
important there are some packages here
that you can look more into that's the
readout package does it read excel
package in Haven read RS is for tabular
tabular data read excel is for reading
excel files into into our Haven is for
reading data from SAS and SPSS and so on
so these are different ways of getting
your data in sois and they all have web
pages that you can you can look into
yourself at a later time there is
there's also data manipulation which is
of course also absolutely important and
I would say is probably what constitute
around 80% of any any remote or any kind
of complex data visualization a lot of
it is simply just a data manipulation
and we won't talk about it you can look
into tidy and apply if you're into the
tidy verse you can look into data table
if you prefer that syntax I personally
don't care what you choose they all have
webpages they all have extensive
documentation and so on
and then we won't really talk that much
about our programming in general like
our as a programming language I do hope
that you're a bit familiar with it
because we're going to look at code
obviously for for the next couple of
times together but but won't really
discuss how the syntax of our is and so
on and I will it's a it's a fantastic
time to not know anything about
programming in the sense that there is a
huge amount of free online material
available alpha data science and
advanced our programming and our
packages are all excellent books written
by Hadley Wickham who is also the the
original author of ggplot2 and they are
all available for free online so go read
these even if you're a seasoned
programmer I'm pretty sure you can even
find things in there that you didn't
know about and it will have more
spillover to how effectively you are
juicing ggplot2 but we will not talk
about today so today we're going to to
be working with well these slides but
there will also be exercises you can
head to this github repository with the
links shown on screen and there will be
both lease these slides will be there as
a PDF but there will also be an hour
markdown file that you can download and
open up and there will be exercises it
won't only be exercises there will also
be code for all the different plots that
I'm showing today so every time there is
a code example and a plot that I'm
showing you the code is actually there
in the markdown file and you can execute
them as we go which I will encourage you
to do just to follow along executing the
code as we talk about it it's a great
way of getting into like accepting that
it's not just my gospel but but it's
actually it's true that when you execute
this kind of code the output looks like
this and a slight detour from from how I
did it during the during the workshop is
that
we won't take off time for you to sit
down and and solve the exercises instead
I will live code them to the extent
possible if you don't want me to spoil
the solution for you you can simply just
commute me if you're watching this at a
later time because this is getting taped
as well you can simply just pause the
video and sit down and solve the
exercises and then continue on with you
with the with a screencast just to see
if everything is working out we have
this exercise our markdown file and this
is this is what you can download from
the workshop repository let us show you
and if you're not familiar with with
markdown files if you open an RD file up
in in our studio you will see that it's
a mix of pros like freeform text and
then we have these kind of weird little
back slashes and along with with some
some different things and in inside here
there are code and code like in here can
actually be executed so if we just slide
down to the first introduction here we
can see that if you if you have your if
you have a cursor on a line you can
command or control and then enter and
this will actually be executed as a
normal our command and when you do that
you can see that we get some output and
usually the output in this in this
workshop will be that of a plot and then
you can just simply follow along as we
go executing the curve and so on and so
forth that's a great way of following
along yeah and I will just jump back so
someone asked what's the link to the
github so the link to the github is back
on it is
yeah she have a link here that was a
good good idea I am new to this so oops
just give me a second
so I just pasted in the link in the chat
room for you okay
so I will try to keep an eye on the on
the chat but a lot of things is
happening and it's probably better for
me to to focus on what I'm going to say
so if you have questions do put them in
the in the chat but I cannot promise
that I'll say I'll see them another
thing that's related to that is that if
you don't have questions and just want
to say hello and so on it's probably
best if you don't just because it will
it will mean that whenever something is
happening in this chat it will be a
question and I'm more likely to see it
okay
I am absolutely amazed by all the people
that are here and I'll just say hello
like this and and and we'll leave it at
that
someone is asking what version of
ggplot2 is needed and it's the recent
version the three point three point oh
that will be working on someone is
asking do you have a delay I have no
idea what that is so I probably don't
it's our mock time stimulus ipython
notebook yes it's quite similar so so
you have you have code blocks and you
have you have blocks of pure text which
is not getting executed and you can you
can just look at it as a as a text as a
as a piece of a text file but you can
also generate PDFs from it and so on and
so forth perhaps just put the link in
the description yes that's an excellent
idea
and I'll just do that there we go
okay so anyway as you can probably see
right now this is all new
to me I have never done a screencast
before so I will try to read through all
your fantastic ideas and comments after
I have given this and perhaps I'll be
more educated about how to probably do
this
the next time so it's this lab coding
you can you can sit in your own computer
and and code with me if you want us to
talked about and the video will be
available later okay let's get going so
let's see okay so let's dive into part
one the grammar of graphics so the
grammar of graphic is graphics it's not
just something that kind of existed
forever it's uh it's something that has
been been developed by a guy named
Leland Wilkinson and it has been been
written about in his book the grammar of
graphics and the first edition came out
in 1999 which last time when I gave the
workshop I said well so it's a pretty
recent book and then I figure out that
I'm just extremely old at this point
which is kind of sad but but that's just
how it is
so the book is kind of interesting is
the thirakkatha reticle deconstruction
of data graphics so it's not really
about how to how to plot things it's
just about what is graphic Cistercian
and and it's a it has been quite
successful in that regard in the sense
that it has been made the foundation for
quite a lot of different graphics
applications ggplot2 is the absolute
obvious one but also the GUI program
called Polaris which later turned into
tableau and also Vega light and probably
others as well so so in that sense it
has been extremely successful in the
goal that it set out to be which is
exactly to create a better foundation
for for software that provides api's for
doing graphics so the book is kind of
interested in the sense that it's not
really interested in why like
why should we choose this box yet why is
a pie chart not as good as a bad shot or
whatever like a lot of data
visualization books are very very
focused on this aspects it's a very
important aspect but but not for this
book like it it doesn't really care
about it it's also not interested in
beauty so it's not a book that you
should read to figure out how to make
like stunning beautiful charts it is
also not really interested in algorithms
like which algorithm should I use to to
create the most efficient map plotting
or whatever like it doesn't really care
about that it is however very interested
in how you design this system that then
can allow all of this and the second
chapter in the book after a brief
introduction is really just how to make
a pie like a pie chart not bake a pie
and and and then this is just a whole
chapter figuring out like like when we
say we wants to make a patch out what do
we have to think about and so on and the
rest of the book is really just a
deconstruction of this thought process
trying to figure out how can we how can
we generalize all of these a deer's and
so on
is it the book that you should like
after this webinar just storm out and
try to get a hold on probably not like
if unless you have read like a dozen or
two different visualization books I
don't think it is that important like
the importance of this book is really in
the different programming packages that
is this inspired and and you don't
really need to read this book to
understand ggplot2 or to understand big
alive and so on but understanding a bit
about the grammar of graphic is very
very good when it comes to comes to
understanding the API choices that that
did you plot to makes for instance so
the idea of the book is that before this
book it was not like there weren't any
theories about about plotting and
visualization such but in general when
it came to when it came to designing
programs or
api's for creating graphics the world
was such that you had a you had a
function that created a pie chart you
had a function that created a power
challenge function to create a LAN
channel and so on and so forth and
that's all well and good like you can
get a lot of stuff done like this but
what he set out to do instead was to say
well this this is kind of stupid in the
sense that we have more than four chat
types and at some point this has become
unmanageable so instead of seeing
looking at these things as just separate
entities he just said well these are all
just representatives of graphics now
this just kind of sounds like well
that's all great but what is graphics
and and well the rest of the book is
really just about that
what is graphics and and and how do you
think about graphics how do you how do
you talk about graphics like what's kind
of capillary do you need and so on so
the book is really a decomposition of
graphics into its constituents and there
is a lot of these these different plus
that I'm showing here on the right where
you have the different constituents they
are all not in complete agreement and
and my version is is earing to the side
of the ggplot2 api doesn't really matter
the the the main paths are all there
anyway so there are all these different
different paths to a graphic like their
data mapping statistics scales and all
that and if it doesn't make any sense to
you right now don't worry we'll have
hours to learn you about this but he
figured out that there are these kind of
cardinal ideas around around graphics
and he also sat down and said well how
old do all these things relate how does
data relate to the rest of the plot and
so on and so forth and this is really
like the grammar of graphics right there
in the same sense that a language
grammar describes different types of
words and different ways that they can
be related to each other
so it's a it's a theory around
structure of language and the grammar of
graphics is a theory around the
structure of graphics okay so so what he
came came forth with was this idea that
we had we had to undo one side this idea
that we have pie charts and bar chests
and all this and then he came with this
idea that well we don't talk about that
over here we talk about themes and
coordinates and facets and geometries
and all that and as you look at this
like his worldview seems much more
complicated than the world worldview of
pie charts outlines can afford right and
that's fair like that's a fair criticism
but but what you should think about is
that I don't I don't think it takes too
much imagination to figure out that
there are there are more than four
different chart types right and new ones
are getting invented everyday and the
interface to creating these these new
plus comes from different people and so
on so like it's not for bubbles to the
left like it's it's a hundred bubbles or
whatever and and in that kind of view
then his idea of maybe eight or eight or
ten different like fixed ideas cardinal
ideas about graphics doesn't seem so
complicated at all right because the
great thing about the grammar of graphic
is that it applies to every type of club
like there is there's no theoretical
hindrance for the grammar of graphics to
not be able to describe any type of plot
in existence now whether the API
supports that doesn't that's a different
discussion and and it doesn't support
everything but it it does support a fair
amount of things right so if we go just
briefly go through these different
different ideas briefly I don't know but
but at least see my briefly in the
bottom of everything is data like
without data you don't have
data visualization you have may be you
may may have a graphics or whatever but
even a graphics without data is kind of
boring right so data is is like this so
most important thing in in data
visualization and data is not just data
like the representation of data kind of
defines what you can do with it and and
even though like the idea of Tidy data
was not that like it didn't exist at
that point the grammar as C's describes
it kind of requires a tidy format he
talks about having accesses to the
different variables in the data that
would return like victor type
information so this is kind of the same
as as a data tidy data frame right so
data is super important we will not talk
more about it but it is super super
important the reason why we won't talk
too much about it is because as we as we
started out with there is simply too
much to discuss about getting data
inside into your programming language
manipulating data and so on so we will
not go into it but data is kind of a big
deal right so once you have data you
have to inform the graphics about how
does the data fit into all of this and
that's that's where the mapping come in
and and the mapping is simply to say
that we have some kind of data set let's
call it iris and and then this iris
dataset has I could call them called
pizza length and pita width and see the
length and siebel with you of course you
don't really have any any programming
API that knows about the column names of
a virus and you don't really have any
any don't really have any programming
api's that expects your data input to be
named a certain way like that would just
be horribly
inefficient so the mapping is what
informs the graphics that well this
column in the data means this and this
column in the data means that and when
I'm talking like that I'm talking about
aesthetic mappings we'll get into to
what aesthetics are later on but but
really it's linking variables and the
data to the graphical properties in the
geometries so for instance this column
represents what should be the X X values
the x axis this variable represents what
should be the color this variable
represents what should be the size and
so on there's the different kind of
mapping in ggplot2 at least which is the
facet mapping faceting is a fantastic
thing that as you can see it's just four
four paths on top of mapping in the in
the stack and faceting is really about
assigning data subsets into different
views and in facet mapping is the idea
that you're also using variables in your
data set to define this this subset
mapping this is all seems kind of weird
but it it becomes more more clear when
we begin to look at it and ggplot2 I'm
using I'm using keynote for the slides
yes it was just because there was
someone asking for it so after the
mapping after we we kind of have
informed the data visualization where
should grab all the values from the data
room we have something called statistics
and and this is something we will delve
into a bit more later on because I think
statistics is some of the something that
trips people have a lot in in G plot too
but in general the idea of statistics is
that even though we may have a fantastic
representation of the data in a tidy
format and all that the data as we pass
in may not represent the values that we
want to display
for instance if we have a we have a bad
shot the bass will usually represent
camps and sure you can you can pass in
some data that already has the counts
pre-calculated but you can just as well
pass in some data that just haven't have
a row for each observation and you want
to let the visualization software method
automatically and the statistics is
exactly that that we apply some sort of
calculations to the data to transform it
into some new values and these values
are then whatever is going to be be
plotted so batch has one thing if we
have a boxplot for instance like this is
retro these have like five different
values that represents the distribution
of some data and you really don't want
to calculate that before you begin
plotting so you need the statistics to
statistics to to do that for you before
we can get into actually drawing the
thing right and for a lot of plot types
this is kind of implicit like you don't
think about the statistics which is also
why it kind of trips up a lot of people
and they can often be done for price
plotting but but usually it doesn't so
when you do a box plot you don't really
think about that it has to calculate
these values it just kind of knows where
to put the different lines and boxes and
so on right well the statistics is doing
all that next up is scales and most
often when you have some data the data
it does not directly represent like the
graphical properties it's it's very
seldom that you have a variable in your
data set that is that has the name
square and triangle and circle in it but
sometimes you want to display the points
with different shapes so you have to
figure out like I don't have this column
in my in my data set but I want like
this this column that represents some
different values it could be
gender or it could be whatever and I
want that to be represented by shape for
instance so we have to apply a scale to
it that map's between like our data
input and into something that is is a
graphic representing so so a scale
translate back and forth between like
the the ranges of variables and the the
property ranges that you have so for
instance if you have categories it can
be different types of caste for instance
and you want to to represent them as
color then you say well this scale takes
care of translating Oddie to red and
Mercedes to blue and so on and so forth
and it can actually also translate back
so it knows that blue is actually
Mercedes and and red is actually
audience so on but it's not only
categories of course like if you pass in
numbers
those are those are continuous and it
can be used for continuous graphical
properties for instance if if you want
to map something to the x-axis we have
numbers and we and we translate that
into positions and that is eye deep deep
beneath it all it's it's mapping it to a
zero to one interval that kind of scales
it correctly inside the plotting region
but that's just technicalities and the
scales kind of imply that there's
there's differences between data like
data can have can have different types
data can be discrete like categories it
can be continuous like numbers it can be
some specific type like like a date or a
time or whatever it can be an ordered
factor and so on and the different type
of scales actually specified the
interpretation of the values right okay
so now we're getting to like the meat of
it which is geometries really this is at
least when you when you're using ggplot2
German Teresa's is more or less all you
think about most of the time and
geometries take care of taking all these
scale values that comes from the mapping
that may have been transformed by a
statistics and say well I'm thankful
that you give me all these values I'm
going to interpret all of these values
in a specific way so for instance a
point geometry will take all these
values x and y values maybe sighs maybe
color and so on and just draw some
points on your plot whereas a geom line
or aligned jeremy tree will take exactly
the same data but it will connect them
right so so the same data input can have
a vast array of different geometric
representation and the geometries are
really how you specify that so there are
some base geometries like pointers we
talked about line polygons these are all
kind of of basic building blocks but we
can also have more complex geometries
like a boxplot geometries takes the
calculator statistics from the boxplot
statistics and it understands them and
knows that it should both create a
rectangle and some lines and so on and
so forth
and the geometries are to a very high
degree what defines what your type of
plot is now is that just simply the same
idea that we have bar charts and line
charts and so on so now we just stuck
with bar geometries and line geometries
and no so on well kind of more done
exactly and one of the things is that
that plus are not limited to two single
geometries and you can have multiple
layers of different geometries but also
right now we have we have kind of
extracted all the
things that also goes into a bar chart
or a pie chart or whatever and put them
into something that's shareable between
different different geometries like the
scales and statistics and mapping and so
on so we talked briefly about fascist
when we talked about mapping so facets
is the idea is that when you have a plot
you have some flooding area and usually
you just have a single plotting area but
you're not really confined to only
having a single flooding area you may
want to split out your data into into
multiple smaller multiples as what is
called an in data visualization of the
same type of plot and this is a
fantastic thing to do and we'll we'll
talk more about when we get into how to
do it with ggplot2
but basically it allows you to to
declutter your data and it allows your
brain to reuse the ideas that it has
from one of the Plus and apply it to the
other subplots and the panel layout like
the layout of the small Sun plus may
actually have meaning so so you can have
a you can have a layout that in and of
itself carries some additional meaning
so the facets are a kind of a weird
concept that that is kind of unique to
to the grammar of traffic in that sense
but it says an extremely powerful
feature and especially when you want to
investigate adjacent like when you're
doing plot driven data and investigation
it's like and almost the last we have
coordinates and coordinates a kind of an
interesting thing right because for a
lot of people coordinates and scales are
kind of the same because we're doing
scaling both of like for color but we
also do it for positional things but
positional aesthetics are kind of
special because
variables after they're being scaled
they have passed the geometries and the
journals free to say well I know what
I'm going to do with this I'm just going
to plot them but right before it's
getting going to plot these things the
positional aesthetics the X&Y well used
or the e everything related to position
it's actually passed through the the
coordinate system and the coordinate
system is kind of the it's a physical
mapping of the aesthetics onto the paper
or onto the screen so so it's kind of
the fabric that you're plotting stuff
into and usually a lot of people will
not really think about this because
we're used to having this Cartesian
coordinate system where we have a
horizontal x-axis and vertical y-axis
right and that's all we think about but
if you're into photography and spatial
stuff you will know that the world is
not that simple it's it's quite hard to
to map a globular world down to to a
flat 2d surface so there's a lot of
different ways that this can be done and
even though we are having the same kind
of latitude and longitude data there's a
lot of different ways that this can
actually be interpreted and the
coordinate system kind of takes care of
this when we're talking about
cartography with we're usually talking
about different projections but but what
it really is it's it's different
coordinate systems right you can so
coordinates are specific to coordinate
systems are specific to the positional
aesthetics there are not really
something that is similar in the same
same sense for the other different
aesthetics I would say it's mainly
similar to a color profile if you know
about color theory because the scale
kind of just Maps things like data input
to actual colors like red blue yellow
whatever maybe even RGB values but what
what these RGB values actually mean on a
piece of paper depends on the different
color profiles that you're used to
printing it with so in that sense it's
like a second layer of translation after
you've done the scaling and and that's
kind of the same as the coordinate
system you don't really have any say in
that when you're when with colors
because it's just like the printer and
your software that takes care of all
that so but it's kind of the same
constant right and in the end the very
least and and also kind of the least
important thing I would say is the
theming and this is really like we
haven't talked about the visual look of
the plot up until now and that's because
it doesn't really flow from the data
itself like which fun should you use
like what's the color of the background
what's the color of the create gridlines
and so on
all of these things are not related to
the data those are related to your
aesthetic sense and what you want to do
with your plot maybe you are going to to
publish it in some some some venue that
has its own style guide and you have to
adhere to that and all that all of these
things are things that that doesn't
really matter in terms of interpreting
in the plot it's just visual flourish
now that doesn't mean it's not important
of course aesthetically pleasing plots
are absolutely much more easy to read
and and likeable than Aquaplus so you
should invest some time in it but on the
other hand it's it's not something that
is important in a sense of how how do we
learn to plus stuff with with DB plot to
or or with any other planning system I
can see right now that I I don't really
have time to to look at the chat window
so I am sorry if there's been an extreme
amount of questions and I haven't seen
them I'm guessing that's just how it's
going to be right now okay so we have
gone through the grammar of graphics in
a quite healthy pace and you may sit
back and think well I just wanted to
make a pie chart
and all this is just like oh my god this
is so so so so boring and theoretical
and so on it let me just make a patch
out and and we get to that and we get to
getting to it now
well not the pie chart part actually
well we'll get to that in the end of the
second part of this this webinar but at
least other chat types so we have
arrived at ggplot2 now I hope you're
still awake I hope you haven't left me
talking to myself because we are all
here to learn about the G+ - API right
and what did you plot - is is what's all
about and and what we have to think
about is that the grammar of graphics is
really just a theoretical design system
and ggplot2 is an implementation and
that's quite important because Headley's
ideas about the grammar of graphics it's
not completely equivalent to little and
Wilkinson's ideas of a gram of traffic
part of that is that Leyland didn't have
to actually invent a plotting a plotting
system and Headley had to and and at
some point life just gets in the way
like you have to figure out how to how
something works and it's actually usable
and you may have to make concessions you
may have to rethink stuff Gd plot 2 has
had to do that and actually continues to
do it because ggplot2 is getting
continuously developed and and we figure
out new ideas a long way but and the
important part is that that well this
period of the grammar of graphics lives
lives on and if you understand the
grammar of graphics you understand that
you put to implementation as well there
are just sometimes technicalities that
differs a bit and as we talked about
before ggplot2 is not like it's not the
only implementation of
przemek graphics like tableau and the
Alliance also out there and and and
certainly there are the flooding systems
that that that uses the same ideas
I think ggplot2 was one of the the first
ones that that came became that became
big and widely recognized and I think
also that g2 has probably inspired a lot
of the other implementations in that
regard but ggplot2 is not like the the
only idea that you can about how you can
implement grammar of graphics like it's
it's just one approach to doing it and
we think of course it's a valid and good
approach but what others can have a
different that use right so code at last
after meet rolling on for a long time so
I don't know if if any of you have
managed to to find the exercise I'm
knock down a file and get it open but
but this is the the time where you can
begin to - yeah this is the time where
we can begin to follow along and and and
do coding as I speak so every time we
have a slide like the one I just showed
you before like this you will actually
have the code lets you have the code in
this exercise as well and you can just
execute it as we go along right and and
if you don't have the code right now
don't worry the the video will be be up
in indefinitely and the the github
repository will be there as well so you
can just go back we rewatch and then
just follow along and your own accord
right okay
so back to you okay so how do we make a
club ggplot2 and we'll just we'll just
take it as we go but we'll actually go
through it in the same
hmm like in the same progression that we
just talked about like fixating on
different parts of the grammar as we go
along but just some some standard API
things when you when we have a standard
ggplot2 plot it will look something like
this right we have we start with a GG
plot call which defines that we are now
creating a GD plot and then we define
some data
the faithful data is something that's
built into our and it's its measurements
of the length of eruption and the time
between eruptions of the Old Faithful
geyser in Yellowstone so it's just there
and it's kind of boring but but we'll
just use it for for show-and-tell
so we we tell ggplot2 on the GG plot
call what the data is and then we have
this mapping that we talked about before
and and the mapping we define with this
es function yes is short for aesthetics
so so everything inside the is years
call will be mappings where we where we
tell the plot well take this column from
faithful and use it for X take this
column from faithful and use it for y
and so on and what you what you will
probably quickly see is that we don't
have any quotes around eruption and
waiting like we don't pass it in as
Springs we pass it in as these kind of
weird language unevaluated language
variables and if you if you're not used
to both the title verse and GD plot you
that might freak you out because inside
our programming environment there's
there's no variable called eruptions
there's no variable being called mating
but in ggplot2 these these calls x
equals eruptions is not evaluated
immediately they are they're kept for
later on and then they're evaluated on
the data so eruptions will be the column
eruption
in faithful and waiting will be the
color waiting in faithful right and then
we add at geometry dude he would just
say geopoint how do we want to draw this
plot and the way we added together is
with this plus and if you use too tight
immerse you will probably be more used
to the pipe right now if you're not used
to the side of us don't worry about it
but in ggplot2 which kind of precedes
the tie device we use the plus sign and
it actually makes kind of semantic sense
that we are adding layers to to the plot
we are adding new definitions to the
plot so it all makes sense and this code
if you execute it in your markdown file
will yield the the plot that we have
here to the right so that's not that bad
right kind of a bit more than if we just
typed plot parentheses faithful dollar
sign eruptions faithful dollar sign
waiting and so on it's a bit more text
right but it's not that bad now you may
see it in a different way as well like
maybe the mapping is placed inside the
geometry
I might trip you up and maybe even the
data is also defined within the within
in geometry and these all yields the
same type of plot where there are slight
differences to it so in the first
version we set a global data that is
getting inherited by all the geums
and layers that we add to it and we
define a global mapping that is slightly
likewise inherited by the different
layers afterwards whereas in this in
this case we have global data but then
we have a layer specific mapping so if
we add a new layer to it underneath it
won't inherit the mapping of taking X
from eruption and Y from waiting and in
this case we don't have any global data
at all we just have data that is
specific to this layer and if we add a
new layer we have to specify some new
data as well okay
so if you want to end in just one last
thing here I've been super nice and just
set mappings equal and data equal and
usually when you see ggplot2 code it's
not that nice like we are so used to
having the first argument of ggplot
being the data and the first argument of
of geometries being the mapping so we
don't really type it out now that's
probably bad practice because unless
you're you used to do plot - it makes
the the code how to read but that's just
the set fact of the world we live in
anyway so so this is kind of the this is
the syntax that I'll use mainly from now
on usually you have some global data for
your plot and usually have some some
layer specific mappings so usually when
I write do you plot to code it will kind
of like this and inside the mapping you
can not only map positions you can also
map all the other aesthetics that we
talked about for instance color and here
you kind of see one of the the great
things about not passing strings into
strings which are names of the of the
columns in the data
because for when we see with color here
the mapping to color is actually an
expression so we can say well the color
should equals whether the the values in
eruptions are smaller than three or not
and it's hard to do that with if we pass
in strings right because there is no
there's no column in your data that's
that means there's no column in data in
the data that that is named eruptions
smaller than three and if you wanted
that you had to pre calculate it and so
on and it will just kind of be more
annoying to work with right
so we can map colors and we can map
everything inside this aesthetic Cole
and when we do that we see that we get
some extra nice things right we get
suddenly we get a guide or a legend to
the right of the plot which takes the
name from from our mapping it's this
eruption smaller than three and then it
says well if it's red it's false if it's
bluish it's true right
it doesn't really surprises us but but
it gives us all these things for free
which is super nice because creating
legends and so on should just it should
be as absolutely easy as possible
because legends guys axes are
instrumental to actually understanding
the plot like if there weren't any
legend here you would have no clue what
the color meant well maybe you could
deduce it in this symbol the symbol
example but but generally when you do
some sort of mapping from data to to
aesthetics you have to give the use of
some way of mapping it back in the head
like how can i how can i interpret this
graphical properties okay now you can do
something else with color which is that
instead of mapping it you can set it and
here we're setting it to steel-blue
which is just a color and what we see is
that we have it outside of our aesthetic
call and steel blue is now a string
giving a color name and what we see now
is that there is no legend because there
is no mapping there is just all the
points have a specific color and and
when we do that we kind of say well I
want the colors to be blue not because
the data dictates it but just kind of
like them blue it fits well within the
theme of my my plot or whatever let them
just be blue right so there's no legend
because it doesn't mean anything they
could just as well be black as an
aesthetic choice okay and this actually
gets into maybe one of the biggest
confusions that I have seen on the
internet when people get started with
with ggplot2 and let's just for losing
my virginity for live coding on the
internet let's just get down to this
example like here okay so this is the
this is the plot that we saw before
right now what happens if we take this
statement oops
and put it inside aesthetics you might
be surprised maybe you've seen this
before but you might be surprised I this
is a stupid plot right we just said that
the color should be still blue and
they're red and also we have this like
weird nonsensical Legend over here like
what what is all this about and well
it's kind of your own fault you're using
it wrong right but but but there's
actually a sense to it so the thing
that's happening is that we're doing
mapping because we're doing it inside
yes here right so so this is a mapping
and we are mapping the expression
expression steel-blue
to color so we're saying that color
should be taken from the variable not
the variable steal boob just like like a
fixed value called steel blue and steel
blue will then be expanded to like it
will be recycled so every every row in
our dataset will get the same steel blue
variable value and that variable will
then be passed into the scale and it
will say well we have something called
steel blue let's map that to red and it
will color everything red and it will
give you a nice legend telling you that
well if it's red is because it has the
value still blue so so this is this is
something that church people level up a
lot and the thing that you should simply
just remember is that if you want to
take something from the data you put it
inside these if you want to simply just
set a thing like I want to define that
the size of the points be equal to two
centimeters or whatever you set it and
you put it outside of our study so if
you just learn this
during these this webinar I think I've
kind of succeeded and and improved the
world of it and everything is back to as
it should be ok let's get back to the
slice so sitting colors as opposed to
mapping mapping colors now points are
not the only only geometry as we talked
about there's a lot of different
geometries and not all geometries have
the same mapping requirements so for
instance you cannot really have a have a
point geometry without both mapping x
and y because we need both these
positional aesthetics to figure out
where to put the points but for instance
if we have a GM histogram we only need a
single X mapping and that's because that
Jim histogram will calculate the Y by
itself simply by saying well I have this
continuous variable called eruption and
I'll cut it up in bins and I'll just
simply count how many things that are
inside the spins and if you just think I
had a bit then yes this is a statistics
that's doing all that so so mapping
requirements differ obviously and you
have to look into the different help
[Music]
sorry you have to look into the
different help documentation for that
let's just hop over here and and look at
some help
ok so for instance gee it's the ground
so if you're not familiar with our
syntax we just have this question sign
in front of it and then just the name of
the function and we get the help the
help entry over here and and if you
figure wondering what kind of of
different aesthetics a specific geometry
you can can understand we can just
scroll way down way down
down this is Oh probably why a lot of
people miss it
[Music]
so aesthetics over here that's actually
a bad example but anyway Jim histogram
uses the same aesthetic as Jim bar so
let's just look at that because that's
more representative so we scroll way
down and we have a steady snow so most
of the the geometries have this section
called aesthetics and it will say well
jumpa understands these different
aesthetics and if it's in bold it's
required you have to do something with
it right you have to you have to provide
something that's X&Y for Jimba and
there's alpha and color and fill and all
these but these are not required okay so
so different layers have different
requirements and different knowledge of
different aesthetics and so on right yep
let's just reset that to this and jump
back since last okay and as we briefly
touched upon before your plot is not
confined to a single geometry or a
single layer for instance here we have
two layers we have a density in 2d
density layer that's shown us as
contours and then we have a point layer
and and here is where the plus sign
looses its its mathematical meaning
because the order of arguments within
the plus sign matters like the first
thing the first layer that you add will
will be below the second layer that you
add so if you look at this if you look
at this plot over here we can see or
maybe it's a bit hard to see but the
point is actually on top of the blue
lines so the order of the addition of
layers defines the order of the layers
in your club okay now that was a that
was not so hard right like we talked
about all these different things and
then in the end all we needed was to
have some data define some mapping and
define some geometries
so even though that we have all these
different theoretical punch drugs we
don't need to apply them to each and
every plot that we make and the reason
for that is that well everything else
has some some quite sensible defaults
not always beautiful defaults but they
are sensible in the sense that they are
understandable and so on so of course we
have all the other things and we can use
that to to further control how the how
how we draw things and and how the the
end result ends up looking and we'll go
through them now right so let's focus on
statistics and if you are confused about
statistics you're not the only one I a
month two ago I did a I did a question
on Twitter foolishly I asked Twitter if
they were if there is a seasoned ggplot2
user what were the most confusing part
of it and one of them was sizing like
how do I ensure that the text is the
right size when I exported and the other
thing was what is statistics like I've
never learned it and I think I think one
of the reasons why it's it's so
confusing is that the statistics and
geometries are kind of linked together
and and those two together kind of
defines a layer and every geom has a
default statistics as far as that as
it's called in GD plot to a lot of times
it's that identity which means just
don't do anything just pass it on but
for instance GM boxplot has a step back
+ and they're kind of linked together so
so usually don't really think about the
statistics because the the community is
kind of coalesced around adding GM to
the when defining layers instead of
adding stats so so when you look at code
you have all these geometries and
sometimes there's statistics or a stat
call cropping oven when what the hell is
that but but basically as we talked
about the statistics are really just
there to to ensure that you don't have
to pre calculate all the values to the
work that you want to plot and sometimes
they're required like sometimes you have
to apply some sort of statistics because
you will like you will never pass in pre
calculated data for boxplot for instance
but other times that then you can
actually like make a choice and say well
I have pre calculated data so I don't
want to apply the statistics so I
overwrite the default autistics don't
worry we'll get into it oh hey I lost
track of myself I forgot the exercises
let's just ignore what I've talked about
in statistics and just quickly jump over
to some exercises because that's what
it's all about right you want to see me
live code and you want to see me screw
up everything because like I wrote these
two exercises months ago so I've long
since forgotten what I actually had in
mind when I wrote them so so I will
potentially mess up and that's that's
good because that means that we can all
learn from it right so one of the
exercises modified the code below to
make the points larger squares and
slightly transparent and then we see CGM
point for more information about the
point layer this was what we just did
with with geom histogram and jimba so we
already have a plot here and and it's it
says we've seen before and it asks us to
to make the points large squares and
slightly transparent now since all of
them should just be squares and all of
them should just be transparent
[Music]
we're not grabbing anything from the
data which means that we are sitting
aesthetics rather than mapping it
so what we can do is that we can say
well this shape aesthetic which defines
the shape of the points we will set that
to where let's see if that works
oh and behold it is now square now what
would have happened if we did this
would that make sense not at all
we run into exactly the same thing as we
did with the colors right so we want to
set it instead of mapping it right and
we also want them to be slightly
transparent like so to understand that
or to figure that out you have to
understand that transparency is
controlled through an aesthetic called
alpha and that may not mean a lot to you
if you're not if you're not well versed
in in color encoding and so on but but
alpha is simply like a name that we
often use for transparency and alpha can
vary between 0 & 1 1 being completely
opaque and 0 being fully transparent
meaning invisible and we should make it
slightly transparent so let's say we do
alpha equals 0.3 and there we go we have
we have achieved transparency in our
squares right then we have another plot
down here which is a histogram as we saw
before and now it says color the two
distribution in the histogram with
different colors and it alludes to that
we have like two different distributions
here and we want to give it different
colors now we might want to do something
like colors equals eruptions let's say
eruptions is below 3.1 maybe
three point one and you will be
surprised by the result because this was
not what we set out to be right we why
is that well in ggplot2 land we have two
different color related aesthetics we
have one called color and we have one
called film and for four things with
Phil then the fill is that it defines
the color of the interior and the colors
that it defines the color of the stroke
and does that make sense well maybe but
that's just kind of a convention you
have to learn it so we don't want to set
the color steady here even though we
want to color it we want to set the
field study here and there you go we
have achieved what we set out to do okay
and what do we have here color the
distribution in the histogram by where
the weighting is above a below 60 so
suddenly now we're not coloring the fill
based on what we already have here the
mapping we already have here with wick
coloring by something else so let's say
equals 60 and what happens here now it
actually does the right thing right it
goes differently but what is what do we
see especially on the left it can be
kind of hard to say to see right here
are they stacked together are they are
they in front of or behind each other
what's actually going on and and if they
are stacked together like how can it
even figure that out and what what's
really happening here is that something
that we haven't really talked about at
all and I don't want to talk too much
about it
it's the dares for each layer there's
also a position adjustment and the
position adjustment can actually say
well after we have scaled everything
reposition something in the plot and for
atiim histogram the the default is the
the stack position which is position
equals stack now if we change that to
say position equals identity I didn't
see what would happen
no there was I was for a minute surprise
okay let's see well we get a different
plot right what's happening suddenly we
can see the rest way anymore and and the
reason for that is actually that they
are behind and and how we can say you
see that is that we can I can see that
you kind of see one typing if we set
make the bars a bit transparent we can
see that they're actually hiding behind
them so it's like it's a sensible
default to have them stacked instead so
we can actually see the different values
but there's no magic going on it's just
figuring out that well we have two
different bars at the same value because
they have two different fields that's
just putting them on top of each other
there are other types of positions
adjustments where you have Dutch for
instance which puts them side-by-side to
each other instead that might be better
at least it's it's clear that they're
not behind each other there's a kind of
a that can be confusion when it comes to
stacked bar charts because only behind
each other or are they stacked we can't
really see that we can see it when we
touch them like this but it's kind of a
knocking play anyway okay so last little
bit of exercise for now add a line that
separates the two
distribution and we're told that we can
look into a plan for how to draw
straight lines from a slope and an
intercept so let's try that we'll add a
new layer and we are using to map a
beeline to do that and I'll have to do
some spitballing here right so what's
what's the slope going to be like from
here to here I would say any good guess
is 40 minus 40
probably slope equals minus 4 y
intercepts pretty high 150 maybe let's
see ah slope is okay um intercepts
should be definitely higher oh that's
too much let's put it in the middle 200
no that's good enough anyway so as we
can see we can gradually build up our
plot by simply saying well we have this
point layer and I actually want to add a
line suit well we'll just add a new
layer to it and that's just that and we
can just gradually build up our plus
with layers and layers and layers and
layers all maybe not that many leaves
but a fair amount of layers at least
okay
all the exercise is done for now we'll
get back here
okay sorry about messing up the
progression of the slides anyway back to
statistics as we talked about they had
to understand and mainly hard to
understand because usually people don't
look at them they are kind of set
default for GMS geometries and people
are usually thinking in geometries it's
it's most often easier to to think about
well I want to add some bass to my Plus
rather than I want to calculate some
counts to my plot and then visualize the
moon with bass so for most people that
the geometries come first in the
statistics is kind of an
- thought especially because a lot of
the times they they have a sensible
default right so every time they
actually do crap up people get kind of
confused because they're not used to
seeing them so if you have ever felt
confused about statistics don't feel bad
everyone has that okay so we just have
this plot you plot MPE we have a new
data set now which is just different
different car types from different years
and so on and we we're going to make a
power plot where where we count them by
class we can see it just happens
automatically so so the MPG data set if
we look at it it just has a row for for
each car and if we'd say Jimba and maps
x2 class it will figure out that well
there are so many there are so many rows
that has the same X and let's just count
them up and then use that to Y
formatting the y
that's because Jimba uses that count by
default now sometimes we have pre
computed data especially if if we have
like humongous data like if we're
talking about billions and billions of
rows for instance well it's not really
feasible to have all that in your
computer just for the sake of plotting
about what right so mater so oftentimes
you will simply ask your your database
give me a count of this and get a much
smaller data set back right but now
suddenly you don't have the data that is
in the format that is expected for for
JimBob so what can you do well you can
say well I don't want this count
statistics instead I already have my
calculated count so don't do anything
don't do anything so just use this
identity stat which is just passing the
data along but now suddenly if you
get the code before we only had to map X
to class suddenly now we have to map Y
as well to the count that we that we
already have in our data right so if you
have pre computed data that conforms to
the requirement of the geometry you can
just set the stat to identity and and
just pass that data along now usually
you actually don't need to do this this
is something a lot of people who need to
do like a few bar with with pre computed
data and that is why we already have a
deal which is Beaufort which is called
Jim Cole and this is simply just jump a
more-or-less with with the with the stat
stat to identity instead and this is
this is generally true actually for
ggplot2 which also works badly for
understanding upstairs the idea that we
have we have geometries as the
first-class citizen and statistics as
kind of a second class citizen means
that for every or for most meaningful
combination of of geometry and stat we
will have a team construction like for
instance with Jim Cole which is you
could say well why do why we have Jim
Cole you can just have a jump and says
that to a tenancy
well it's getting used enough that that
it makes sense to have a shortcut for it
and and this is in general how we
approach it so so if there's a
combination that is it's generally
usable for a lot of people you will
usually see that we have a shortcut
constructor for it and you don't have to
think about stats once again now the
stat is doing stuff obviously it is
calculating new values under the hood
for instance account now what if you
wanted to do something with that what
what if you wanted to do something with
the values that comes out of the staff
well if you're an old-time did you plot
to user you might you might know that
there is a stat function stat
parentheses for accessing these values
if you're even older ggplot2 user you
may remember the the weird dot variable
name dot dot notation I'm not going to
show it here but anyway which is used to
define to say that well this aesthetic
is scrapped from the stat it does not
exist in the data that I pass in weight
with the valuation of this aesthetic
until after the statistics has been
calculated this kind of a weird concept
but in the new version of ggplot2 we
have this we have kind of consolidated
all these ideas and instead of stat or
thought that we have this after
underscore stat function which is used
to to mark an expression for evaluation
after the statistics has been calculated
and I know this all sounds probably very
very weird but for an example if you
have GM bar and it has to it calculates
count and instead of count you actually
want to have percentage of the whole now
you can really access count outside
outside of your data because it's only
getting calculated when plotting right
so what you can do is that you can have
inside after stat you can map Y to 100
times count which is getting calculated
by this debt and and divided by the
total of count and then we get the
percent wise values for each bar instead
right bit weird and it's it's okay to
not grasp it completely but it's it's
it's kind of a good thing to gradually
begin to learn and get
comfortable world especially because
many stats provides a lot of different
calculated values so step count for
instant for instance also have
proportion which is if you have multiple
groups within the same within the same x
position then the proportion will give
you the proportion of each group within
that and so on and you can access these
with the axis that function so for
instance so for instance here we have
Jim density which cross the density
curve for for mpg and for the highway
yield that means how much how many
gallons of fuel does it take to to move
the car and the default is to give
density at any given point but a lot of
other things have been been calculated
for us
for instance the stat density also
calculate a scaled version of the
density and if you want to use that
instead of the default you just simply
do it by it by saying after stat and
then just grab the other calculated
column which is called scaled now how do
I know which kind of things that a
different statistics is calculating how
do I know what can get accessed any way
well I think GT platoons is pretty
reasonable documented and if we just
jump down here and say ask ask are about
it there we go so if we look at the the
documentation for GM density and step
density as we see here I scroll way way
way way way way down just as before we
see we get to the esthetic pad up here
and we get to below that we have
something called
computer variables and the this is the
output of the stat so it defines here we
have one computed out output is density
which is the density estimate then we
also have count and it defines how
countless actually calculated we have
scaled we have n density so on and and
every stat will have this if they are
calculating new stuff and so you can you
can again go into the help entries and
figure out this stuff okay okay so that
was that I hope that I have demystify
this a bit
I know stats are kind of a weird concept
and I've said that a lot of times now
and it's simply to make sure that you
don't feel bad about being a little
freaked out about what stats are and if
you don't feel freaked out about it it's
just perfect but but it is a bit weird
but but you can simply think about it as
a pre plotting transformation of your
data and that transformation could just
as well happen in your own code before
you do the plotting but often times it's
just much more convenient that it's
going getting done as part of the the
plotting routine and the status
responsible with that and the stat can
calculate a lot of different things that
you may want to use and sometimes it's
just completely completely invisible to
you and sometimes you want to take
control of it's right but it's simply
just a data transformation pipeline that
sits in between your definition of the
input data and the geometry that's
getting a show okay
after stat is defined where so it was
just a question from the chat that I
quickly store
so after status new which means that it
is new in three point 3.0 so if you have
not upgraded ggplot2 it doesn't exist if
you have upgraded ggplot2
it should exist and it it takes over
from the old stat function and from the
very old tattered function now the the
very old that that function and slightly
less old stat function will continue to
function and work I don't know for how
long but for a long foreseeable future
like we don't just yank out
functionality from GG's plot - and and
make all your code break but after stat
is it's the new vetted version the
reason why we have added it is because
that we have also added something called
after scale which is which is a
completely new concept but also because
that is kind of it doesn't really define
what it means so after status more
verbose in the sense that it says after
the statistics has been calculated do
this grab it from here so we think it's
it's it's a bit more clear and in in the
API what it's actually happening even
though you have to type a bit more but
we think that's that's worth it
okay so we are getting two scales now I
should remember that now we should
probably have some exercises when it
comes to two scales and I missed up
something here there we go okay so there
are some exercises for this test as well
that we'll just go through down here so
here we have our favorite power plot
again and then we talked about most
people use GM underscore whatever to add
layers to your plot but it is actually
just as valid to to a stats instead and
they will have an attached geom and they
will have a default view and so it asked
me to look at Jim bond figure out which
standard you syste fall we've already
talked about that it's it's Jim count or
step count
and and then modify the coach yu's
that's that directly instead so how
would we do that well we will simply say
is that count and no because I am
horribly at spelling is that count and
we get exactly the same result now the
reason we get exactly the same result is
that the default GM for stat is power
but we could set do something funky and
say Jim equal Y instead now what will we
get then I will get this slightly
useless plug but anyway just to say to
show that that geum's have defaults
tests which you can override if it makes
sense but stats have default gyms that
you can also override if that makes
sense to you so you're actually in
complete control but usually you don't
mess with that unless you know exactly
what you want to achieve because the
defaults are are pretty sensible okay so
the next the next question you stat
summary to add a red dot at the mean
it's W Y for each group so let's just
look at the plot first okay we have this
it's a jitter plot using G of jitter and
we we have the points grouped by the
different different classes and then we
have highway yield on the y-axis and it
asks us to add a red dot at the mean
value for each of these groups so what
we want to do is to use step summary
which is a stat that allows us to pass
in a function that calculates something
sort like we're actually in very much
complete control
that's summary and we'll have the same
mapping again so X is equal
and Y is equal this and then we can see
we have some different we have some
functions that can that can calculate
different different things around our
data and we just use fun here how does
it mean now what happens if we do that I
actually don't know let's see well it
did something like there's a bigger
point in the middle maybe you can see
that but anyway I removed seven rows
containing missing values gym segment
that is weird right gym section we
didn't talk about gym segment in any
part of our code up here this is
actually because the the default giome
for stat summary let's just have a look
at that summary summary the default geom
is point range now that's the different
gym we haven't talked about that and we
don't really need to talk about that
right now but safe to say that we did
not we did not provide enough
information for the point range gym and
doesn't matter because here we just want
to add a point so we say gym equals a
point and we also set the color to red
right let's see if that makes sense okay
it's a bit small let's make it bigger as
well
it's a bit bigger now okay
so here we here we have a stat summary
that allows us to define various
different summary statistics for
calculating a single value for a single
value for four groups of data and we
could change this to be median for
instance and we get a slightly different
different output as well okay oh I even
gave a hint you'll need to change the
default key Jim there we go okay we will
back to scales now so if you remember
from the first part scales is used for
every type of mapping so if we map
something from our data to an aesthetic
then we need to scale it because for
instance classes of cars like SUV
doesn't have a geometric representation
right we need to to convert it to
something else that makes sense in a
planning context and the scales does
that so everything that you put inside
the ears call will have a scale and and
if you don't provide anything by adding
to it it will get a default one and it
will pick something that is kind of
sensible and it will pick a default
based on the the type of data that you
have met so it's discrete or continuous
so on and so forth and this is why we
haven't really needed it before because
it simply just picks reasonable defaults
for us but if you want to take control
you have to add them specifically and
scales follow see my predictable name is
you in the same way that you have GM
underscore you have scale underscore and
then we have the name of the aesthetics
for so for instance
we have scale on the score collar and
then we may have underscore or something
else and that's something else is why I
see my predictable because it might be
scale underscore color underscore
continues which which gives kind of the
type of the interpretation of the data
but especially for color we have all all
these weird different color palettes and
they can they can be named in this type
argument as well so the last part of the
scale name is kind of unpredictable yeah
I just had to collect my thoughts there
okay so let's have a look here so up
here as we've kind of seen this before
we don't own we're not only mapping x
and y we're also mapping colors to
something we met in the color to class
and and what did you put two does in
this instance is that it looks into what
type of mixer is class like the the
result of the of evaluating class in the
context of mpg which results in the the
class column in mpg what type is that is
it a number is it is it a character
vector is the fact so make sure it's
date column like what kind of thing is
it
and it looks into the class and you can
see well this is a thing as effexor xr
not a victor Thanks
and so it says well this is discrete
data so we map a discrete scholar scale
to it and it just picks the default one
which is it's this one and it's not
necessarily pretty but it works but it's
there and it kind of works and it
creates all by itself it creates this
nice legend for us so we can understand
the color mapping and map back and forth
now this is not a great plug a lot of
the plus I'm showing you a not great
they were meant for illustrating the
the API more than it's meant to
illustrate house would make a great plus
so just take take the actual visual
appearance with a grain of salt now what
if we don't like these colors whatever
we want to map to Sita to something
other than dress because we don't like
this this tinder red or whatever well we
need to add a scale to it and kind of
take control and say we don't want to
use the default we once you use this one
right so so after we have defined our
our layer we can add this scale color
and then we say ruler now what screw
there is a color color collection of
color palettes called color blue which
are quite sensible generally they are
sensible in the in the sense that colors
have been chosen so that they are
perceptually uniform and there's not a
single color that Springs out in your
mind and generally the the palettes that
you have in in color brewer are designed
in a way so you you won't cheat yourself
and you want sheet the peed the the
persons that you're trying to
communicate with so they are not
necessarily all of them beautiful but
they're good step in starting stone in
terms of of picking some new palace
without making horrible choices and
color is super important and once more I
will not go into much detail here but
color color is one of the it's one of
those things that you can you can create
beautiful plus with beautiful color and
you'll end up fooling yourself because
the colors are actually not picked in a
way that so that they represent the data
correctly you may also use it for
nefarious means don't do that I don't
hope I have to say that but don't try to
cheat with your visualizations but
usually people don't
usually people don't do this willfully
but they may end up cheating or fooling
people with their visualisations because
color can can be so difficult to work
with and the color Brewer is a good
starting point because they have been
designed in a way that that makes sense
the same is true for Reedus which is a
continuous color scale that is that
tries to to be to be good at not having
any banding and have perceptually
uniform steps for for the same same
value difference yeah anyway as you can
maybe grasp color is a huge area and and
I hope someone else will make a bit an
hour about it because I'm not going to
talk too much about it more okay anyway
we can take over the the default scale
by adding its explicitly and we do that
here with scale colored Brewer and as I
say here
well scale naming is kind of predictable
but everything inside the function the
scale function is not that predictable
there are some arguments that that will
appear in all scales like for instance
you can give a name to the scale so
instead of just grabbing the name class
that you see in the legend instead of
just grabbing that from the madding and
the scene Jim point we can give
something explicitly let's just try that
for more fun there we go
so this is the plot where we're looking
at right and so every every scale will
have a name argument where we can say us
because we look like we like all caps
and we can see that the title is
actually changing here right so this
will be in all the scale function but
mainly the scale of the arguments and
the scale function will be specific to
that specific scale functions
for instance the type argument is
specific to the brewer scales because it
it understands that the Brewer scales
has been designed in such a way that
there are different types of scales
there qualitative there are sequential
and divergent and and you can control
that with the type argument but that
doesn't necessarily translate well to a
shape scale for instance or whatever so
you will usually have to look into the
documentation generally when you begin
to use a new part of the API Fuji you've
got to just that by reading the
documentation because a lot of the
information is already available in
there and and there is there are simply
a lot of information and you can't be
expected to understand that on the
get-go so just sit down and and read the
documentation to figure out where all
the different nuts and bolts are for
right okay back to scales now when
you're talking about scales you you may
think about many color and shape scales
but x and y are also controllable scales
and if you have continuous x and y
values you're using scale underscore x
occur on the score continues and scale
underscore Y and score continuous and
you can use that both to change the name
as we just saw but we can also use that
to change things such as where do we see
breaks where do we see gridlines we do
that for the the X scale here where we
said well we don't only want breaks or
gridlines at 3 5 & 6 and for the for the
y scale we set a transformation now the
transformations that's something new but
every scale has a transformation built
into it as well and again usually the
transformation is the identity
transformation which means do not
transform the data but sometimes you may
want to transform the data for instance
you want to have your data be lock
transformed as we do here
and we say trends equals luck 10 now of
course because a lot of people want this
their data luck transformed we already
have a building shortcut for it so you
can also ask a LAN just go why on the
score luck 10 so use it as however you
want it
so those scales and I think I have some
amazing amazing exercises about that as
well let's see exercises ok so we have
this plot here which is the plot we saw
before right use our color Brio display
blue all to see all the different
palettes from Calabria and figure favors
modify the code below to use it so we'll
need to call this function let's just
put it down here ok so so when you call
this function this is not a nice plot
there's simply not enough space to show
the names of all of these nicely but
anyway so these are all the different
palettes that you can use from from the
color Brewer and these are all
accessible through scale color
underscore Brewer and when we say type
equals qual we say type equals quote we
just say well our data is qualitative so
use one of the the qualitative color
scales which are those in the middle
here
it's called stitch with a three said to
pestle 2 X n 2 and so on and it will
just pick the first one which is
excellent and in the same way if we said
that it was divergent it would just pick
the first one of those now I don't know
about you but I really really like set
one so instead of just saying which type
it is I can name the palace directly
with the palette
argument and we'll have a new palette
one that is really nice
so so this single function scale color
brew has a lot of different color
palettes build into it and as we'll talk
about later there's a lot of extensions
that provide even more different color
scales especially access to different
many different palettes so if you're
just looking at adding a sprinkle of
color to your plus like the world will
provide for you and we'll talk more
about that later ok so we have a plot
here not a beautiful plot I will mainly
promise you that none of my plots will
be beautiful but they will be educated
and the question is modify the code
below to create a bubble chart a bubble
chart is a scatter plot where size is
also mapped to a continuous variable and
oh my god I have forgotten to to delete
the solution I'm spoiling everything for
you this should be the second one said
okay with size map two continuous
variables showing cylinders with size
make sure that only the present amount
of cylinders four five six and eight are
present in the legend okay so what are
we going to do well we mapping size to
still there okay
now this doesn't look like we had it
before right so the first question is or
the second question is to make sure that
only the the present amount of cylinders
five four five six and eight are present
in the legend now in the legend here
it's also generated and it just it just
takes the range of your data and defines
five equidistant breakpoints and shows
the size for that
now we have a set amount of up sizes and
we may want to just show those because
here this implies that we have an entity
with seven cylinders which we don't so
so this legend is kind of not cheating
but it's it's kind of confusing to to
read this so the way we do that is that
we say scale size and we'll just say
scale size no just scale size and we'll
say breaks equals four five six and
eight and now we can see that our legend
correctly reflects what we what we have
in our data now this this mapping let's
just talk about that for a while because
this mapping kind of looks weird it
feels like four is mapped way too small
compared to the others now mapping sizes
is generally a tricky thing and and when
you when you just close your eyes and
think about how you want to do that then
the easiest thing is to map it to the
radius of the circle but but that will
that will generally be a bad idea
because when the eye look at a point it
will look at the area it will not
perceive the radius it will perceive the
area so you want to to map it to the
area instead and if your method to to
the radius then the area will grow too
fast and and last value will appear even
larger in your plot so if we just show
you can do scale you can do the bad
thing and map its radius and it actually
it looks better right now in some sense
but if you look at it it actually feels
like like size is increasing exponential
I would say so that's a bad idea right
but the other thing looks weird as well
right like like forest is way too small
and it feels like the jump from 4 to 5
is it's much bigger than the jump from 5
to 6 it actually is not bigger and you
have to take my word for it it's just
because four is more or less nothing and
then suddenly there is something and the
ANA size increase from from five to six
from something to something more doesn't
feel as abrupt one way to to get over
this is to say use the scale size area
the skin size area will use area scaling
but further than that it will it will
also ensure that zero and your input
variables will also be mapped to a zero
size in your in your in plot so we have
a much more natural progression of sizes
here they are much more difficult to
discern because the range of sizes is
much more but it feels at least more
natural and and we can make the range of
sizes bigger by saying max size equals
say instead for instance and we have a
bit more spread in the sizes right okay
I think that was what I wanted to say
about that okay modify the code below so
that color is no longer maps in the
discrete class variable but to the
continuous city city yield variable what
happens to the guy okay so we have this
guide here and color is currently mapped
to class and what happens if we instead
of mapping into class habit to City
now city is it's new or change the stuff
because suddenly city the mapping to
color is continuous instead of discrete
and this means that the the color
palette will also be continuous like it
will be a gradient more or less and when
you have a continuous color mapping
ggplot2 will by default choose a new
legend for you as well which kind of
shows this gradient nature of the color
mapping now you can you can control this
and there's actually the last last
exercise we have this year this is the
same flood right yes
so you can control the type of guide
that you the type of legend that you
have over here and and you can do that
either within the scale but you can also
do it in this guy's function where you
can just say color what kind of guy do
you want for color and now the the
topmost guys the one that we have
precise is called a legend guide and the
the button most the one that we have for
color is called a color bar guide so
even though that we have a have a
continuous color mapping we can actually
use the the old style the old style
legend card and we can do that by just
saying that the legend should be the
color legend should be the legend time
now what happens now
now we have now we have two two
different aesthetics both maps in the
same variable namely City yield and they
are also shown with the same type of
guide and then ggplot2 is smart enough
to actually understand that these two
guides or these two these two guys can
be collapsed into one so instead of I'm
showing the two guys and the condition
just yeah compress it into a single guy
this is nice because there's a it makes
makes it much more clear that both color
and size is map to the same thing now
the the the guide merging is not
foolproof actually it's it's kind of
super stupid which means that it only
merges guides if they are exactly the
same and if they're not exactly the same
they will not be merged so if we for
instance do scale size and give it a new
name like we just like to show the two
guys are no longer completely the same
because they have different names and
ggplot2 just gives up
I don't know how much these they don't
look at all like each other so I can't
do anything
so the merging is kind of stupid I hope
to be able to improve it in a later
version of ggplot2 in general the guy
system is one of the old vestiges of old
ggplot2 and and it's it's the only thing
that is currently lacking from complete
rewrite so that will probably happen and
hopefully smart a guide merging will
will be part of that ok and we are on
two facets so let's jump over there okay
so facets is fantastic facets are
absolutely amazing and and should be
used all the time almost the idea behind
facets is that you can take your input
data and you can split it into multiple
panels now it is not the same as having
multiple different plots as such because
each panel has has the same underlying
plot logic so so we will reuse the same
scales it were
use the same coordinate system it will
reuse the same mapping and so on so they
are they are the exact same
representations of of the same plot but
the data differ now fezzes has also been
used to kind of try to combine multiple
separate plots because people often want
that and it has not been easy to do that
in GD plot to for a while but it is easy
now with extension packages that we will
talk about in the next webinar so
because there are absolutely better ways
to do that now
you should not butcher facets into
trying to do that you should use passes
if you have if you want to create small
multiples and that's basically it if you
want to have the same type of plot
repeated over and over again with with
differences in the data now one of the
reasons why this is such a good idea
is that it is one of the most effective
ways to avoid over plotting usually all
plotting is the concept that if you have
simply to have too much data and tries
to add points or lines so whatever
inevitably it will just end up as a big
blob of black or whatever like it will
be impossible to see how many points are
laid on top of each other even if you
became to make make things very very
transparent at some point you just have
too much data and will get over plotted
now one of the the best ways to combat
that is through faceting because you get
a lot of small multiples and small
multiple sizes it's sensible because
they are related to variables in your
data and mentally like carnac it's
getting laid over here
your mind will actually be able to reuse
the knowledge it gained from reading the
first panel like it will
understand how the plus should be read
and it can apply that to all the other
small multiples so it's so cognitively
it's much much easier for the head to
wrap around small multiples and in
ggplot2 it's very very easy to do this
kind of faceting which is also why you
should absolutely be doing it all the
time you plot to provides two different
facets and facets are extendable which
means that there are extension packages
out there and that will provide even
more different ways of faceting plots we
may talk about them later I can't
remember but did you plot to provides -
one of them is called facet wrap and as
we can see here the way the facet wrap
works is is that it's sorry I lost my
thread again as wrap takes a column from
your data here the class column and as
this this tilde which mean it kind of
looks weird now but it's it's there for
a reason it has this it is tilde and and
just kind of says take the class
variable map the class variables to
panel and it will automatically create
all these small subplots and as you can
see the small stuff plus they they share
the same axis so it's it's very very
easy to compare one small subplot with
another and it's actually just much also
much more easy for you to compare the
different classes in a small subplot
view when compared to plotting plotting
in a single panel and showing the
different classes with for instance
color or shape so this is much more easy
for you to digest and understand because
your eyes can focus on the different
classes one at a time and make
comparisons between them very very easy
another type of faceting is the the
facet grid it's kind of like facet wrap
what we talked before here was that
fasten trap just takes all the different
classes and it just have one panel for
each class and it will just wrap all the
panels into into like a ribbon and use
as many columns and rows as necessary to
to show all the classes now if as this
grid is a bit different it's kind of a
graphic pivot in the sense that it can
take two different variables and set
them beside each other one will be on
the columns and one will be in the row
and each pal each panel will then show
the intersection between the in this
example here and drive
so the first topmost top left panel will
show all the points that are from 1999
and have a four-wheel drive so it's
extremely it's very very easy to make
very very refined sub plus with these
kind of fascist functions and that's all
I have I think I'm having to say about
fascist for the time being you can do
more more advanced stuff with them but
basically this is the interface that you
need facet wrap or fascist great
depending on whether you want to make to
look at just a single variable or two
variables and then how they have the
interact and let's just see what my
exercise will be so not a lot of
exercise anyway we have this plot a
fastest of plot one of the great things
about fascist is that they share the
axis between the different panels this
is a good thing in general which the
reason why it's a good thing is that we
can be sure that the the look whether we
have in one panel can be just completely
overlaid to the next panel because
have the same positional access and so
on so usually you want that but
sometimes you don't and you can you can
change this behavior with a scale
document so let's just try and do that
so here we have C scales now this can
take three different values we can say
scales equals free and this means that
each panel will have completely free
free exit scales and what we can see
here is that they now they have their
own y-axis each of them have their own
y-axis and the x-axis is no longer the
same down here right now you may think
that this is nicer because all the
points fill out the entire area they are
much more you're zoomed into each area
but when you just look at it you have no
sense in in terms of how you can compare
the two or three different different
panels so this is this is less effective
in terms of communicating the underlying
data now as I said sometimes you may
want it sometimes you may not you can
also just free one of the scales instead
so we can say free Y and we can see that
now the x-axis is actually fixed but we
have different y-axis for each of the
panels and likewise with free x we can
see that's now the y-axis is yet between
all of them and the x-axis differs
between the different panels yes
so the next one usually the space
occupied by each panel is equal as we
can see up here they all of them are
equally wide this can create problems
with different screens are used so let's
see here
here we have like this is a horrible
plug right and the reason why is a
horrible plot is that they actually the
reason why it's horrible is that they
share the same the same scale because
2-seater for instance they only have
representatives from one manufacturer
and compact has representatives for some
other and so on so a lot of space is
being wasted showing no data and this is
an an amazing possibility for using this
space argument where we can space a
space equals three why I think that will
do it no that will not do it and the
reason why I will not do it is that we
still have fixed scales so just let me
so now we're getting into the late live
coding pad okay
this worked so what we can see here now
is that when we have free free scales to
kind of combat this this loss of combat
this amount of white space that we saw
if we don't have free spaces as well
what we see is that each panel will
still take up the same height in the
data so so the the 2-seater has the same
height as the compact even though it
only represents one observation and it
kind of looks weird right so what we can
do is with the space spaces argument
space argument we can also make the
space free and this will mean that the
space is relative to the amount of data
the range of the data that it represents
right so now we ensure that all of the
paths are equal and we don't have any
any empty space that takes up our plot
and it's much more readable now
okay see I'm almost out of water let's
see so last thing is fascists can be
based on multiple variables by adding
them together we didn't talk about that
in the slides but we'll just briefly
whistle here and when adding them
together they kind of takes again the
intersection between the different
variables so when we have a passive grid
here where we say here and drive will be
the defining variables for the faceting
another way to show this a less
effective way but another way to show
this is to use facet wrap and then
instead saying drive here now how will
that look now we can see in another way
that that four-wheel drive in 99 1999
will have this panel and 4-wheel Drive
and 2008 will have this panel so it's
the same panels but they arranged in a
different ways so we lose the idea of
having rows that have the same the same
variables and columns that has the same
variables so I will argue that this is
this is a less effective way of showing
it but just to show that well we can
actually do this we can add variables
together to get even more fine-grained
subsets of the data so we don't have
we're not confined to only using one
variable in our data okay of course
combinatorially the amount of panels
will explode if you begin to add like a
lot of columns and a lot of combinations
together that's just how it is okay back
to quarters
yeah so almost there I am I'm happy for
the people that has as hold out till the
end I know the it's it's late sometimes
so very early sometimes and we talked
about coordinates it's kind of the
fabric that we're drawing onto what kind
of of kennels
should we draw it and when you think
about it when we think about that we we
are thinking about how should x and y be
interpreted so the coordinate system
does not mean anything for color for for
shave and whatnot but it but it takes it
goes in and it modifies x and y and one
thing that is particularly relevant is
that both limits and transformations can
be applied both in scales and in
coordinate systems now that seems weird
and there's there are several subtle
differences in where you can apply these
and and these subtle differences are
often lost and and this results in in a
lot of head-scratching and a lot of
people that gets weirded out by the
behavior so it's a good thing to know
about coordinate system because usually
you want to do transformations and a
limit setting in the coordinate system
rather than the scale if you can so
basically the difference is that scales
will be applies in the beginning so so
scales will take your input data and it
will scale it before before your your
team gets it and that means that that if
you're if you set the limits and you
have data outside of the limits that
data will simply just vanish it will
disappear whereas if you set limits in
the coordinate system that that data is
still there because the limit has not
been enforced yet and it will only be
be changed at the very very end of
everything
so coordinate systems basically doesn't
change anything about which data is
there and how the data looks kinda but
it does change how it's getting drawn so
we'll look into that furthermore
coordinate systems extremely useful in
Katoch rafi and as we talked about with
map projections and so on there is not a
single best way of drawing the whole
earth into 2d there's it's all about
concessions and figuring out what's
important for this particular plot so
there's a lot of different ways of
transforming longitudes and latitudes
into x and y representations on the
canvas now we have only looked at a
Cartesian coordinate system now for now
which is like this idea that X defines
the horizontal position and Y defines
the the vertical position and there are
other coordinate system built into into
ggplot2 one of them is called polar
which is a polar coordinate system and a
polar coordinate system interprets x and
y in a different way it interprets x and
y as radius and angle and and this
results in a very very different plot so
so this GM bar plot that was would
usually just be a bar plot it's
certainly what we will call a wind rose
and when you change whether x and y
whether X is mapped to radius or exam
it's mapped to angle or when you change
that around we get a very very different
plot so now we can get this kind of a
circular race chart if you have an Apple
watch I guess it's kind of reminiscent
about the activity view there
so this is none of these plots are
particularly informative but this is
just to show that the coordinate system
has a huge say in terms of the final
look of the plot because it it takes it
takes all the data that's getting
through all the pipeline and then it
just says well I know that you have an
idea about what to do with this data but
I define the universe that you can plot
it in i define what x and y are i define
how they relate to each other and I
define how everything should be drawn so
coordinate system has a huge say in how
the final look of your plus it's going
to to be now most plus at plus are drawn
in a Cartesian coordinate system so
usually you don't have these kind of
weird complete transformations of your
plot as we see with polar but even so
even if you're only using Cartesian and
coordinate systems it's a very good idea
to know about the course and the reason
for that is particularly relevant when
you're trying to do some zooming in
usually when people try to zoom in on
their data they will set limits to the
scale and as we talked about that's one
approach here we're saying well we have
this GM bar bar plot that we have seen a
lot of times and now I want to zoom in
so that the the plot is between 0 and 40
on the y axis now this looks weird and
we get this warning as well remove three
rows containing missing values now why
did that happen
well it did happen because because when
you have when you set a limit to your
scale you define the limits of what the
scale understands and if you have values
outside of the limits in the scale they
will get bigger than be removed because
they have no meaning in the plot so
it'll just be removed so so these limits
have actually removed
the bass for compact and midsize and SUV
because they were higher than 40 and
usually when you assume you don't want
to have that right you want to you want
to keep like the representation of your
plot you just want to zoom in and you
can achieve that by zooming within the
coordinate system because here you're
just kind of stretching the fabric
you're not removing anything you're just
changing the area that you're looking at
so if we do exactly the same with with
cut Cartesian and then set the wild
limits to zero to 40 then we get the
look that we're looking for right and
that along with not puddings aesthetic
settings inside es but outside is
probably my second main takeaway because
that's the other big big surprise for a
lot of people it's not only by
surprising in that it removes stuffs but
but for certain things such as polygons
and so on it will remove some of the
points and the shape will be completely
distorted and people don't realize that
it's because this if zoom limits within
the scale instead of within the corner
of the coordinate system so if if your
purpose is to zoom then always do it in
the coordinate system if you just
remember that everything will be fine
it'll be okay we can do this so I am
pretty sure I have a few exercises for
coordinate systems before the last last
part okay so we have this plot there we
go and in the same way as limits can be
said in both the scales and the
coordinate system transformation
canceling can as well we can do that
using the core trance coordinate system
which is a Cartesian coordinate system
where you can just add transformations
to two X or Y so modify the code below
to apply a large transformation to the Y
axis
first you scale why continues and then
use cold trends so let's see what
happens here actually so scale why
continues what do we have you now that's
not a beautiful plot right and the main
reason why it's not beautiful is that
the breaks in the y axis are horrible
now why are they horrible this is
because that the scale will transform
the input values prior to doing any
brake calculations so it will take the
input values it will it will transform
them and then just from there on now
these are the new values and this also
means that when when trying to figuring
out when trying to figure out the
correct break points it completely
messes things up now if we instead do
for trans and can't remember the
arguments it's just yes
y equals slack hopefully we'll get
something that's slightly more beautiful
right so this is this is the look that
we want and the reason why it's it's
better is that the breaks and break
points has been calculated on normal
data we are just kind of stretching the
fabric so that it matches a lock
transformation and again this idea of
just having a fabric that you can kind
of stretch and do transformations with
after the plot has actually been placed
upon the fabric is it's a very good
metaphor for what the cut the coordinate
system is actually doing and it also
makes it quite easy to reason about why
it's behaving in a more sensible way
usually than doing things in the scale
instead and yes so and we talked about
and we're not getting into that much
spatial data and cartography because
that is also a huge area and I'm not the
best person to educate and done you
educate your honors but coordinate
systems are very very important for it
and ggplot2 has a great support for
plotting maps especially with the newish
GMS F and then quarters F and let's see
and which interface with the fantastic
sf package so if you're doing spatial
stuff you should use the SF package and
you can plot with with G to plot to
using G MSF so the reason why it's so at
coordinate systems are so important as
we've talked about it's very very
difficult to to map globally a data into
a 2d representation that is truthful so
if we just we just create some we will
not do that today I have no idea why my
computer is freaking out about that
anyway that is for you to try out maybe
you don't get this this area but but the
time is already too late for you to look
at me trying to figure it out so we'll
jump on to theme that's the joy of life
coding I guess there we go
so this is the last part of the first
part of the of the webinar just slightly
small discussion about theme and as we
talked about themes are religious
stylistic changes to the plot and they
are not related to data in any way so
that's just whatever you want in terms
of aesthetic style and and indeed you
plot - geez / - has a fantastic theming
system and it's both possible for you to
to modify theming with a completely
pre-packed theme but you can also both
add a pre-pack theme and then do small
per element modification to it
afterwards and one thing to take away
especially is the theming is radical it
is not as if you are a web developer of
tribe web development it is not the same
as CSS but it kind of captures some of
the same ideas that the things are here
at Google and let's just have a look at
it so we have all all the other pluses
we've seen before has Eustace this
beautiful gray background that everyone
loves about ggplot2 but if you want to
be a rebel and not use the gray
background you can do that by adding
another theme to it and here we're just
adding the minimal to this plot and we
can see that the gray background is gone
in in favor of a very very minimal style
which is actually one of the styles that
I I usually prefer so it's very very
quick to change the overall look using
building themes and also and again we
will talk about this later
or we'll talk about this in the next
webinar there's a lot of extensions that
come with with built in themes so you're
not confined to only using these these
predefined themes you can also go crazy
and say well here we have minimal and
then I'm also doing all different things
and I'm targeting specific parts of the
plot area to really create and make it
the exact way I want to so just to go
through this is absolutely the longest
ggplot2 code we have we have seen yet
it's a we start with ggplot it's using
the MGP days as we know and using GM
power and juicing faces wraps then we're
using the the laps function to set title
and it's also setting a caption
which is small text that's below the
plot and then we are sitting x and y
tiles to know which kind of removes the
removes the the titles from the x and y
axis and sometimes that's actually a
good idea because we don't really like
the the y axis is pretty
self-explanatory like SUV subcompact
pickup and so on we don't we we don't
need to know that that's a class of car
furthermore the title number of cars car
models per class actually tells us
what's x and y are anyway so we can just
remove it and remove redundancies then
we change the expansion of the scale
axis that's not as important then we add
theme minimal and then comes like this
huge theme chunk where we do like
additional modifications to the theme
and we say well for the text I don't
want to use the the default text I want
to be like highbrow and fancy and use a
veneer next condensed which is a super
fancy font and we we define this using
element text function now the reason why
we don't just say text equals Avenue
next condensed is that well there's a
lot of settings to text right there's
both the the family that we're setting
here but also the size there's also
whether it should be italic or bold or
whatever and all these settings is kind
of confined inside this element text
function and we use the hierarchical
nature of the theming by setting
stripped up text is again equal to
element text its
inheriting the Avenir next condensed
because strip text is a it's a child of
the text the text element and now is
just safe say that it should be bold and
we don't want to be centered we should
just have it left justified and we do
the same with with the plot caption is
again element text would just say it
should be at a lake instead but it's
still evan your next condensed because
that's inherited from text just to show
that we can also change other things
than just the funds and the text
so the panel grid we changed that to be
white using the element line and we
changed the size of it
and then we remove the minor and major y
grid lines as well and we use that we do
that using element blank an element plan
can be added to any element just say
don't don't draw this element at all
just ignore it completely
and then at least at last there is
there's a few settings that that doesn't
take some of these element underscore
functions but just take a single scalar
value so panel on top is a switch that
says well the gridlines and so on
draw them on top of the data and now we
have this this very very different look
and all of this just goes to show that
you can do a lot of different things
with the theming system and you can
achieve almost exactly this specific
look that you want with with ggplot2
you're not confined to this this default
gray background that people usually
recognized from ggplot2 and that's it
because next time and I still don't have
a date for that hopefully next week we
will begin to talk about the extension
system so hopefully you've gotten a
grasp about the ggplot2 API and not just
the idea that there are a lot of
different functions but hopefully you
have gotten some idea about the logic
behind it that there is a reason why
there are GM's and scales and so on and
hopefully and I really really hope that
this is this has come across this this
theoretical underpinning to the API this
grammar of graphics means that you don't
have to know all the different gems for
instance you don't need to know the
complete API of tu plus 2 you just need
to know that if I want to change how
data looks like which how to draw the
data I should look into GM's and if I
want to change something in terms of
which colors are used to sounds so
like that I should use into scale so
hopefully hopefully this has come across
because this this theoretical
undercurrent that lies in the API means
that there's the sense to to all the
decisions that we make and once you get
accustomed to that that logic it becomes
much more easy to navigate inside
ggplot2 and and hopefully this the
theoretical start has actually made made
you grasp that sense a bit more you see
that's at least my hope for it so that's
it for today I I thank the people that
have stuck with me throughout throughout
this presentation and I hope to see you
again potentially next week but look out
for my well for this YouTube channel I
will I will advertise the the next part
of the webinar here and I will also
advertise it on Twitter so thank you for
today and Oh last thing I have not been
able to take any questions during my
rambling here so I will try to to go
through all of the the things in the
chat and if there are some some very
very good questions I'll try to answer
them in the beginning of the next the
next part I think that makes more sense
than than stepping up every time so
thank you all and enjoy the rest of
potential time I hope to see you again
in the next webinar thank you